madame
vous ne me connaissez pas vingt-cinq ans
après le vote de la loi qui porte votre
nom je voudrais vous dire combien vous
avez raison de vous bas madame contre
tous les matchs isme c'est une vieille
dame qui vous et les conservatismes
à 20 ans j'ai failli mourir lors d'une
ivg clandestine je voulais vous dire ma
gratitude et ma reconnaissance pour la
loi pour l'avortement madame j'espère
que vous serez enterré au panthéon
permettez moi d'ajouter mon nom à ceux
des très nombreux français qui vous ont
témoigné leur admiration respect et
reconnaissance
à l'occasion de votre entrée à
l'académie française
magasin m200 quatre travées sont 28
quelque part dans le labyrinthe des
archives nationales des centaines de
cartons qui contiennent des archives
privées de simone veil 81 m de
rayonnages où se mélangent documents
officiels et papier plus personnelle de
son discours annotés de sa main prononcé
à la tribune de l'assemblée nationale en
1974 pour défendre les vg au compte
rendu du conseil des ministres
mêlés à des correspondances privées ou
des agendas autant de pièces qui
témoigne de l'imbrication de la vie
privée et politique de simone veil qui
pourrait paraître anecdotique mans
important sur le fond et qui dans la
forme ont un intérêt que je prends tout
simplement un discours par exemple
qu'elle a rédigée lors des élections
européennes de la campagne des élections
européennes de 1984 elle parle de
l'ouverture de l'europe au monde
est ce que je trouve intéressant c'est
la façon talent a construit son discours
dans la personne qui lui a rédigé à ses
relectures aux corrections de son mari
et on voit comment est ce qu'en fait sa
vie familiale était très présente dans
sa vie politique dès 2012
cinq ans avant sa disparition simone
veil procède à ce que l'on appelle ici
les premiers versements et ils vont
s'enchaîner au rythme d'une donation par
an une mémoire républicaine
ininterrompue quasiment tous les
épisodes de sa trajectoire sont couverts
de la france à l'europe de la fin de la
seconde guerre à des activités plus
littéraire elle a laissé elle l a laissé
des traces très organisé très structuré
et très consistante
donc en fait à partir de là sa mémoire
ici est complètement présenteront va
transférer ses cendres certes mais la
mémoire est l'oeuvre de simone veil et
sa pensée et ce qu'elle veut léguer se
trouve se trouve ici indéniablement
étant donné l'importance de ceux de ce2
[Musique]
une mémoire dans les archives qui
commence par la magistrature
simone veil à 27 ans tout juste diplômé
de droit
elle choisit l'administration
pénitentiaire devant les réticences de
son mari elle renonce à une carrière
d'avocat mais pas à rendre la justice
simone veil ce qui était d'abord sa
première caractéristique c'est qu'elle a
voulu travailler
elle avait déjà je crois deux enfants 3
et elle a voulu travailler et là elle a
choisi l'administration pénitentiaire ce
qui est extrêmement rare
parce que la direction administration
pénitentiaire est naturellement une
direction très rude
elle a été vraiment reconnue comme
quelqu'un ayant joué un rôle décisif
dans l'évolution des conditions de
détention et en particulier l'évolution
des conditions de détention des femmes
les femmes étaient moins nombreuses que
les hommes en détention beaucoup moins
nombreuses elles n'intéressaient pas
vraiment parce qu'elle ne se mobilisait
pas une elle n'était pas dangereuse donc
on les laissait dans une sorte de des
intérêts quand il ya eu simone s'est
occupé du transfert des femmes de la
prison d'haguenau confirmait à la
centrale de rennes pour les peine
définitive on interdisait aux femmes
d'avoir des photos de leurs enfants
je ne sais pas si vous imaginez ce que
ça peut être sur le plan de d'essayer de
réintégrer dans la société les femmes
parmi les pièces retrouvées
un procès verbal comme on on rédige des
centaines par jour dans la haute
administration
ce jour là c'est simone veil qui tient
stylo et préside la séance de la réunion
sur les droits et obligations des
détenus si la cellule n'est pas chauffé
le punit doit pouvoir garder à sa
disposition durant la journée un nombre
suffisant de couverture la lecture est
permise et les détenus poursuivant des
études doivent avoir à leur disposition
le matériel scolaire qui leur est
nécessaire
il doit être laissée aux punis papier
crayon pour qu'il puisse écrire
il y avait quelque chose d'incroyable
d'un probable qu'elle se retrouve dans
cette administration pénitentiaire sur
des questions carcérales et pourtant ce
que je trouve remarquable c'est que
justement à cette fonction elle va être
celle qui va penser un rapport à l'udm
aux conditions de vie c'est-à-dire un
souci de l'humanité ou de la justice
dans ce monde derrière les barreaux et
c'est comme si vraiment son expérience
allez en permanence trouver une
traduction particulière dans son souci
des autres dans des postes les plus
incroyables ou improbables dans les
têtes dans lesquels en tant que femme en
tant que femme politique et en tant que
femme politique ayant connu la
déportation el vasco se trouvait
[Musique]
pendant la guerre la famille vite à nice
et pensent eux chapet au raf arrêté en
avril 1944 au lendemain des épreuves du
bac
la famille est séparé la jeune simone
jacob va d'être déportée avec sa soeur
et sa mère
d'abord au camp d'auschwitz puis à celui
de bergen belsen
[Musique]
papa chéri denise et jean nous sommes en
bonne santé milou et moi et quand on
venir vous retrouver rapidement mais
nous ne savons pas si c'est à cette
adresse que nous pourrons vous joindre
nous pensons sans cesse au moment où
nous serons réunis et en attendant nous
vous embrassons plus tendrement que
jamais
[Musique]
et
et on
elle reviendra à paris seul avec sa
soeur en mai 1945 mais ne reverra jamais
son père et son frère et déportés de
leur côté en lituanie
il y aller
retour à la salle des tris à thenon au
quai de déchargement des archives
nationales
on y retrouve constant de vergnette le
conservateur en patrimoine en charge des
documents de la famille veille et
aujourd'hui parmi les milliers de notes
elle a trouvé un document exceptionnel
sept pages de réponses dactylographié à
un questionnaire adressé à la jeune
magistrate dans ce document elle
explique comment sa déportation par
exemple a été même si elle avait la
vocation d'être avocate ou de travailler
dans le domaine juridique avant avant
cet épisode sa déportation a été plus ou
moins un déclencheur aussi de cette
cette envie de ce besoin de s'occuper
des autres d'une attention plus
particulière aux plus démunis lequel
explique exemple ce paragraphe
elle vit de décider depuis mon
adolescence à être avocat pour des
raisons plus ou moins bonnes d'ailleurs
l'expérience de la déportation n'a fait
que confirmer cette intention
espérant alors pouvoir faire quelque
chose pour les condamnés ou anciens
condamnés victimes de leur passé de leur
milieu et de leur misère donc là on y
trouve tout ce qui explique en fait se
sont subitement dans la vie
professionnelle
en le voyant on pourrait dire que ce
document n'a pas forcément un intérêt
particulier
mais c'est en le lisant plus
profondément en voyant ses réponses qu
elle a toujours été fidèle à ses
principes et à ses convictions et que ce
document écrit en 1960 elle aurait pu
très bien le leur écrire en 2000 en 2014
enfin après récemment elle va se soucier
de ce qu'on peut encore offrir à cette
autre pour qu'ils gardent une dignité
pour qu'ils puissent se relever
et là encore la question de la
résilience qui est si central dans sa
vie et qui en fait sa propre résidence
qu'elle raconte par ces actes politiques
est omniprésente
comment on fait pour que l'autre se
relève pour qu'ils puissent ans
être
[Musique]
pagesjaunes
mais 1974 les français élisent un jeune
président de 48 ans et découvre un
nouveau visage celui de simone veil
contre toute attente et contrairement à
ce qu'annonce certains journaux la
magistrate n'est pas nous mais à la
justice
valéry giscard d'estaing confiait la
première femme ministre de plein droit
de la vème république
le portefeuille de la santé et l'immense
tâche de mettre fin au drame des
avortements clandestins
il s'agissait de 250 à 300 milles
avortements par an clandestins en france
dans des conditions de santé tout à fait
dramatique avec des morts des femmes
devenues stériles et de toute façon il y
avait 2 1 deux voies pour un
gouvernement de ne pas laisser
s'installer ce risque permanent alors
que dans des pays comme la belgique ou
la suisse
à l'époque les femmes qui a eu on avait
les moyens allaient se faire avorter le
combat elle a mené bien un truc d'abord
au sein de la majorité qui soutenait le
gouvernement puisque je rappelle que
huit mois avant en décembre 1973 avait
été rejeté un projet de loi présenté par
le garde des sceaux d'époque jean
taittinger et qui en gros dépénalisé
l'avortement et ça avait été repoussée
assez largement et c'était les mêmes
députés
c'était la même majorité parlementaire
puisqu'il n'y a pas eu dissolution après
74 qui étaient en face d'elle et donc
elle avait un courant qui t'a fait
considérable a remonté le débat a
commencé à l'assemblée nationale le 26
novembre
1974 à 16 heures edgar faure en jaquette
pour marquer la solennité de l'événement
et les montées du rhône depuis 6
milliard d'années sanctions son discours
je le dis avec toute ma conviction
l'avortement doit rester l'exception
l'ultime recours pour des situations
sans issue mais comment le tolérer sans
qu'il perde ce caractère d'exception
sans que la société paraissent
l'encourager je voudrais tout d'abord
vous faire partager une conviction de
femmes
je m'excuse de le faire devant cette
assemblée presque exclusivement composée
d'hommes
aucune femme ne recourt de gaieté de
coeur à l'avortement il suffit d'écouter
les femmes c'est toujours un drame
[Applaudissements]
c'est toujours un drame cela restera
toujours un drame
c'est pourquoi c'est l'un des documents
les plus précieux les plus émouvants de
ses archives
le discours écrit par simone veil a noté
de san l'un des traits rouges pour
souligner les mots importants et les
respirations a observé qui accentue la
solennité d'un moment historique
simone veil alors qu'elle était novice
en politique est encore plus je dirais
en relations avec le parlement a eu
l'intuition qu'il ne fallait surtout pas
qu'elle affronte cette majorité
globalement hostile sous l'angle
idéologique
elle s'est donc bien gardé de présenter
le texte sous l'angle d'une proclamation
des droits des femmes de la liberté des
femmes à disposer de leur corps au
contraire simone veil a dit c'est une
question de santé publique
les débats se déroulent dans un climat
hostile souvent violent comme en
témoignent les notes prises par simone
veil depuis le banc réservé au
gouvernement pendant l'examen du texte
son écriture vacille quand elle note ce
jour là la phrase prononcée par le
député centriste jean-marie d'aillet qui
compare les vg à l'extermination des
juifs dans les fours crématoires
moi je téléphonais la nuit en me disant
tu vas en enfer
voyez c'était pas très grave mais c'est
vous dire le climat un député venu à la
tribune avec un bocal dans lequel il y
avait un foetus pour dire voilà ce que
vous voulez faire c'est tu es en bas
c'était surtout là une énorme influence
de culte catholique des catholiques
c'est à dire c'était le foetus est un
être vivant
donc c'est un crime et comme vous savez
un certain moment petit moment de
faiblesse et on
vu les larmes tenir ses yeux le deuxième
ou le troisième jour de quoi de ce débat
en réalité ce qui a compté ça a été
l'attitude de la gauche la loi est
minoritaire à droite et elle est
majoritaire ultra-majoritaire quasi
unanimité à gauche et ça ça fait que
simone veil a toujours eu
de ce point de vue là une une aura une
réputation qui dépassait les frontières
de 2 de la droite du centre le 29
novembre 1974 dans la nuit le texte est
adopté
mais simone veil n'est pas dupe de
l'engagement féministe de sa majorité
lors du conseil des ministres du 24
décembre de la même année alors que
valéry giscard d'estaing se félicite de
l'avancée des droits des femmes
simone veil se laissera aller à ce
commentaire un peu acide pour les
ministres présents ce jour là ce n'est
pas vrai qu'on est en avance sur la
politique à l'égard des femmes
il suffit de voir les misogynes autour
de la table
[Musique]
dès le lendemain du vote les lettres
afflux celle du député lucien neuwirth
qui a bataillé sept ans plus tôt pour
autoriser la pilule celle de ses proches
ou d'homonymes harcelés par les coups de
fil de félicitations
mais plus inattendue celle de l'évêque
auxiliaire de paris
madame la ministre permettez moi de vous
remercier d'avoir accepté au nom du
gouvernement l'amendement qui préserve
la liberté de conscience des directeurs
d'établissements privés
j'imagine sans peine ce que ces jours
représente pour vous
soyez assurés que les grands débats sont
aussi ceux se noue une profonde estime
pour ceux qui les assument avec toute
leur humanité
[Musique]
toutes les archives de simone veil n'ont
pas encore livré leurs secrets
le dernier versement vient tout juste
d'arriver
ce sont les documents qu'elle a gardé
chez elle jusqu'à la fin comme cet
agenda de 1979 année charnière
simone veil est choisi pour mener la
liste centriste au premier élection du
parlement européen au suffrage universel
elle passe du ministère de la santé au
parlement européen
dans la même année elle a deux fonctions
complètement on va dire complètement
différente
voilà non là on commence par exemple je
suis ici nous avons au mercredi 20 juin
conseil des ministres donc elle a encore
dans sa période ministère voilà avec la
présidence de giscard d'estaing et puis
alors au mois de juillet on passe on
passe plus sur le parlement européen
voilà un rendez-vous à luxembourg ce qui
était un avec bruxelles et strasbourg
un des points 2-2 réunion du parlement
européen hasard des découvertes cet
album ou sur des dizaines de pages elle
a collé des photos de ces affiches
placardées dans paris souvenir d'une
première campagne électorale elle qui
n'a jamais battu des estrades ni
tellement aimé s'exposer c'était de très
loin elle qui s'imposait comme il
fallait une figure qui soit connue des
français très populaire qui incarne un
engagement européen très profond et qui
incarne la volonté de modernisation de
la société française auquel à laquelle
valéry giscard d'estaing souhaité
associer son septennat
et là il n'y avait pas photo voici le
résultat du scrutin ont obtenu monsieur
amendola 47 voix
madame va
192 x
monsieur zagari
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le fait que ce soit une juive une juive
qui avait été déporté juif dans toute la
famille une grande partie de la famille
avait péri en déportation
le fait que ce soit elle qui choisissent
l'europe c'est est infiniment porter ça
voulait dire que tout le monde devait
choisir l'europe et or elle m'a toujours
dit que quand elles étaient rentrés de
caen
elle avait très rapidement poser le
problème en ces termes pour nous soit on
tue tous les allemands ce qui était
évidemment pas une option une absurdité
soit on repart complètement à zéro et
ont fait ensemble quelque chose de
différent simplement l'audace l'audace
intellectuelle l'imagination la
générosité de simone veil ça a été d'en
tirer immédiatement toutes les
conséquences le défi de la paix tout
d'abord dans un monde où l'équilibré des
forces a permis jusqu'à présent d'éviter
le cataclysme suicidaire de conflit armé
entre les superpuissances
on a vu se multiplier en revanche les
affrontements locaux je trouve que sur
le plan européen
c'est une époque extraordinaire mon
féconde le parlement européen est élu au
suffrage universel en 79 mais par l'acte
unique européen au milieu des années 80
il obtient un droit assez compliqué mais
un droit de participation réel à la
décision législative c'est-à-dire à la
fabrication des règlements et des
directives alors qu'avant ils n'avaient
qu'un pouvoir consultatif dans tout le
monde se moquait
pendant quatorze ans simone veil va 1
l'aca blement plaidé l'europe
redevenu simple député européenne elle
se rend à berlin en 1989
au lendemain de la chute du mur pour
fêter la liberté retrouvée
elle qui a toujours eu une inversion
pour les régimes autoritaires
d'où qu'ils soient
quelques années plus tôt désigné docteur
honoris causa de l'université libre de
bruxelles en même temps que nelson
mandela elle écrira au président
sud-africain et demandera à recevoir son
prix en présence du dissidents
politiques emprisonnés pour terrorisme
avant de recevoir une lettre catégorique
de refus au mot plus qu'équivoque d'un
pouvoir qui défend encore la supériorité
d'une race sur l'autre chère madame je
trouve surprenant que les membres du
jury de l'université libre de bruxelles
puisse décerner dans la même promotion
le titre de docteur honoris causa à
votre honorable personnalité et à nelson
mandela chef d'une organisation
terroriste
je suis convaincu chère madame qu'après
les épreuves que vous avez subi pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale vous êtes
d'accord pour rejeter la violence d'où
qu'elle vienne
veuillez croire à l'assurance de ma plus
beaux sidération
[Musique]
après deux années au ministère de la
santé qu'elle retrouve dans le
gouvernement de cohabitation d'edouard
balladur
simone veil quittent progressivement la
vie politique sans grand regret pour les
batailles d'ego qui s'y joue et retrouve
dit elle une liberté
simone veil qui n'a jamais fait de son
appartenance à la communauté juive ni de
sa déportation un argument va désormais
s'occuper de perpétuer la mémoire de
toutes les victimes de la déportation à
la tête du mémorial de la shoah moi je
me souviens personnellement et comme
petite fille de déporté que la voix de
simone veil était comme la conversation
où le récit de ce que mes grands-parents
ne pouvais pas m'offrir
moi j'ai grandi avec un héritage de
silence où les choses le drame de la
shoah a été transmis par le silence et
par le non dit il ya beaucoup de choses
qui passent aussi par le silence mais
quand la voix de simone veil et d'autres
survivants surgissait et bien les gens
de ma génération petits enfants de
déportés
on était dans un silence que je
qualifierais de religieux pour entendre
ces mots qui nous nous manquait dans nos
histoires familiales
albert consul hélène muller comme tous
les ans au mois de mai devant l'école
primaire de l'hospitalière saint gervais
à paris ces élèves égrène les noms des
260 enfants juifs arrêtés au même
endroit en 1942 par la police française
lors de la rafle du vel d'hiv
si elle saluera la reconnaissance par
jacques chirac en 1995 de la
responsabilité de l'état français dans
l'arrestation et la déportation des
juifs de france
simone veil s'opposera toujours aux
amalgames et dès 1960 à la diffusion par
le rtf du film le chagrin et la pitié
dans ce documentaire le cinéaste marcel
ophuls des temps une france passive plus
que résistante et pour simone veil
rescapée des camps la vérité impose de
ne pas désigner des français comme tous
coupables qu'est ce qui a dû sans doute
lui déplaire c'est l'ami sur le même
niveau de gens qui avaient fait le choix
de la collaboration et même de la
collaboration militaire de gendre canton
recueilli le témoignage sur leur
engagement aux côtés des forces des
forces armées allemandes en russie etc
et puis des résistants dont il y avait
une façon de mettre sur le même niveau
les les deux camps qui était
certainement quelque chose d'assez
insupportable pour elle c'est comme si
en toute circonstance elle refusait d'en
fermer l'autre dans une seule image de
lui même et ce qui vaut pour son
interlocuteur individuels semblent
valoir de son point de vue pour la
nation française
il n'est pas question pour elle de
laisser ce narratif là le narratif d'une
culpabilité général ou d'une tâche
collective raconté la france est raconté
sa france et c'est comme si elle avait
un souci permanent de dire il y à cette
histoire
mais ce n'est pas toute l'histoire il y
a eu ses actes mais ce ne sont pas tous
les actes il y a eu ces français mais ce
ne sont pas tous les français et encore
une fois la possibilité d'être autre
chose
pendant neuf ans enfin elle va siéger au
conseil constitutionnel avant de devenir
membre de l'académie française en 2010
je crois que ce qui m'a toujours frappé
chez simone veil c'est la combinaison de
deux choses très grand engagement
personnel une sensibilité extrêmement
forte à toutes les émotions les épreuves
les confrontations qui ont jalonné sa
vie c'est une femme elle réagi très
fortement avec son intelligence avec son
coeur et en même temps une capacité de
mise à distance intellectuelle et de
prise de conscience très rapide de ce
qui doit être fait quand on met les
passions au vestiaire ça c'est le secret
de sa personnalité politique se
mélangent d'hypersensibilité et 10
paires lucidité le 1er juillet 2018
avec son mari elle aura rejoint le
panthéon
[Musique]
elle sera seulement la cinquième femme à
y est entré
[Musique]
on
mais c'est en seine saint denis aux
portes de paris que ceux qui voudront la
lire la comprendre et s'inspirer de son
héritage devront se rendre
magasin m200 quatre travées 128
c'est là qu'ils trouveront chez archiv
aux côtés quelques mètres plus loin de
celle de son mari
moi je pense que c'est celle là que je
prendrais pas ce que parce que c'est la
plus jeune c'est celle peut-être là le
regard le plus résolu
je crois que c'est celle là parce que
c'est la figure qu'elle a dans les
activités qu'elle a eue ou de ministres
ou au parlement européen
alors j'ai choisi moi j'ai choisi celle
ci elle regarde l'objectif on al
impression qu elle nous regarde nous il
ya un regard qui est grave mais en même
temps il ya la tendresse si particulière
du regard de simone veil
je pense à celle là on a on a là la
femme du bilan qui regarde ce que ce qui
a été fait et qui au bout du compte
trouve l'apaisement et en même temps une
vigilance intacte
[Musique]